i think it's fair to say 2020 has been a
very stranger but what a waste of a year
it would be if we let this year go by
without taking away
lessons that you and i can prepare for
so we don't repeat the same mistakes
again
in the future so today i'm going to
share with you 15 lessons i learned
from 2020
[Music]
so let me get right into it i think it's
fair to say that point number one is
pretty much going to set the tone for
the other 14 points
and here's what point number one is
every decade
or so we have a massive crisis in
america every decade there's a massive
crisis
2020 pandemic 2008 2009 market crash
2001 911 every 10 years a big crisis
takes place
however you and i never know what the
crisis is
because if i were to ask you right now
which one was more surprising
911 or the pandemic you may say well
pandemic's more like hurricane because
you know how they say in about five days
the hurricane's gonna touch down in
houston and such and such so you have
five days to kind of board up the place
versus 9 11 was like wait what what
happened a plane
flew into a building no way yeah man
what a what a terrible pilot
boom second plane flies into the
building no no it's not a terrible pilot
it's an attack america is under attack
out of all the countries in the world
we're under attack yes we're on
surprise right every 10 years there's a
crisis the challenge with crisis is
they never look alike they're all
different they're all different
but the process of going through a
crisis is the same so
for instance if you're married right now
and my wife and i were talking to you
then i was telling a couple of my peers
that are married they were saying what
is it like being married all this other
stuff they're just getting married
i said look in your 20s you can eat
anything you want you still have a
six-pack
in your 30s you're gonna have to start
watching your diet because if you don't
watch your diet
you're going to get fat you can eat two
pizzas it's going to be bad issues
40s flexibility goes away 50s i don't
know but i asked 50 year olds
60 is what happens do you know every
decade you
age there's a new crisis that you're
going to face every decade
you fake when you have kids it's fun
they're in the house then they leave the
house
now you realize did you actually get
along with your husband and wife
because there's no kids in your house no
now what do you do now you're kind of
fighting and saying listen can you leave
the house
honestly i can't handle you being
hearing but the point is 20
different crisis 30 is a different
crisis 40 is a different crisis
50s crisis is not
going away no matter how much money you
make no matter how rich become no matter
how strong you become
we're always going to have a crisis next
one this leads me to
what happens when there is a crisis
everything about
pandemic taking place if you go back and
look at the pandemic taking place within
your family friendship company industry
whatever you did
i guarantee you somebody became a hero
let me say this one more time
to you i guarantee you somebody in your
family
became a hero why they were the most
poised they were prepared to calm your
nerves
everybody else was rattled this guy
brought you down every company in your
company if you thought about there was
somebody that calmed your nerves you
looked at the
you know zoom company did you're like
why does that guy not seem nervous
you kind of watch this person and their
numbers blew up they did better
look how come that person's calm
a crisis is almost always a filtering
process
to identify new leaders look how many
people became heroes in america
during the pandemic you almost need
a crisis for us to introduce to next
layer of leaders to the world
family company industry world politics
it always takes place number three
when the pandemic took place there was a
big debate prior to prior to the
pandemic
everybody talked about cash is not king
cash is not king
never leave money in cash never leave
money in cash and then the pandemic kids
you know what everybody wanted more of
cash people didn't have cash
so because people didn't have cash and
because we don't teach people who to go
back to the basic fundamentals of saving
money
people don't have cash so guess who had
to bail out all the people
who didn't have cash the government did
and the government gets their money
their cash
to bail out other people with cash from
who
the government goes and gets the cash to
give to other people that don't have
cash
from those who have cash which is who
the taxpayers think about what i just
said right there to you
cash is king so if you weren't obsessed
about saving money and having a lot of
liquid cash the pandemic definitely
taught all of us
cash is king number four research in
order to come to your own conclusion
you can rely so much on fox cnn nbc cbs
you can rely so much on new york times
new york post washington times
washington post money magazine time
magazine forbes fortune
you can rely so much on it but at the
end of the day you are the leader of
your household
you got to go out there and do research
for yourself you got to go out and find
out exactly what's taking place
you got to go out and find out exactly
what the laws are we are learning so
many different things right now that we
had no clue about
look at the election this is a very
weird election we're learning new laws
what happens if this thing keeps going
at what point does a president have to
concede what if he doesn't concede
what is a pandemic what does a pandemic
do what is a coronavirus
why is this thing viral what is the are
not score what is things that we never
thought about we started researching so
too often people when something bad
happens to them
they rely on everybody else to tell them
what's the right thing to do
rather than them doing the research
moving forward
rely on your own ability to research
not just the pundits that tell you
their research you got to go to your own
research to find out what's being said
out there what's taking place
next one look one thing we were forced
to learn is how to
work remotely most people had no
collateral work remotely most people
didn't know how to hold
their employees accountable or remotely
most people didn't even know how to be
held accountable remotely
through using zoom we were forced to
learn how to do that moving forward
you have to make sure your company knows
how to do that which leads me to point
number six
business models were questioned meaning
door-to-door business models were
questioned people didn't want people to
come and knock on their doors
i don't think people are still gonna
want people to come and knock on their
doors
a lot of business models were questioned
so are you going there sitting down and
asking your business partners now that
things are pretty much slowing down
and pandemic is gradually i know some
people say well listen we just crossed
10 million
we're having a bigger stay all this
other stuff and europe shut down uk 30
days i totally get it i totally get it
but people are a little bit more
comfortable today with it
than they were six months ago pfizer is
coming out with a vaccine ninety percent
a fake
efficacy score you know we're kind of
going through the process that we have
right now as we go through it
regardless if the pandemic is gone or
not is your business model
pandemic proof if it's not you may want
to consider sitting out with your board
and auditing your business model number
seven don't
let emotional people make decisions for
your family
i saw so many families screwing up
decisions because they let the most
emotional person
in their lives make a decision for them
why would you let an emotional person
that everything is the end of the world
make decisions for your family you don't
do it that way you simply sit there and
say
bob mom dad cousin honey whatever babe
i love you but babe please we're not
making a decision like this
let's relax a little bit here's what
we're going to be doing it's not the end
of the world this is what's going on no
no i understand
i understand i understand you're afraid
i understand you're afraid
but here's what we're going to be doing
as a family boom boom boom boom boom
and you bring everybody down too many
people gave the keys
of their life to an emotional leader
don't do that it's
very problematic if you do that take
control never give the keys of decision
making process
to the most emotional person in your
family they can make some very bad
decisions that can send you back
set you back five or ten years next
number eight building a business with
small margins
isn't sustainable if you don't have a
ton of cash which is the airline
industry
going on three and a half percent of
margins how do you expect to sustain so
what do we have to do we have to bail
out the airline industry because they
don't have a lot of cash because
their margins are small and on three and
a half percent of margins that's a scary
industry to be a part of
so airlines and some industries that are
going off of very small margins and
they're not sitting on a lot of cash
at any point a bad six-month stretch
you're out of business
so some of those smaller margin
industries if you're in it you may want
to kind of plan to
get out of those industries if a small
margin or figure out a way to come out
with a new way of doing business
and not the same way that people have
been doing it for a long time whatever
that may be
point number nine predicting the future
is risky business even experts
don't know everything we saw fauci he
was a name we never knew
prior to the pandemic did you know who
found she was if you did you're probably
60 years old
or 55 years old if you know who fauci
was most people had no clue who fauci
was
but one minute fauci goes up and says
masks don't work
another minute three months later he
says everybody should wear a mask even
experts get it wrong even experts don't
have
all the answers even experts after
research
learn more to give new insight on what
needs to be done
so don't look at experts at as the
almighty oh they have every single
answer still
go do your own research even even
even when that expert has been chosen by
the president
you still go do your own research point
number 10 is the power of media look i'm
not trying to tell you we just found out
the media's as powerful media has been
powerful for a very long time
but they are more powerful today than
ever before why
because everybody's was all eyes on the
media during the pandemic so they became
the source for everybody
and that leads me to point number 11 the
power of social media
and citizen journalism the person that
was recording
the eight minutes and 46 seconds of
george floyd was a girl holding an
iphone 19 year old girl
holding an iphone recording while the
cop had his knee
on george floyd the power of social
media
why is this so powerful today let me
explain to why it's so powerful today
i was watching that documentary what's
it called social dilemma i believe right
and you know what's one of the things
that i do agree with them
on the power of social media so you got
media power social media which takes me
to
the next one which is the power of
emotional reaction and they all go
together watch this
you know pre this pre having a cell
phone
back when only rich people had a cell
phone i don't know if you remember those
mercedes where they had the
car phone and the wire in the car phone
and then people had cell phones
but it was only rich people it was few
thousand dollars you didn't have a cell
phone you were rich
when you saw a person with a cell phone
the brick you were like oh my gosh this
guy's a millionaire
everybody today has a cell phone there's
a problem with this here's what's the
problem with this
sometimes you need 30 minutes before you
make a decision
let me unpack that you're on a drive
home
your brother pissed you off okay
something happened
you call him right off the bat you text
him you're you're a loser i always
knew you were this dad was right about
you
you're a piece of what you said what to
dad you're a dirtbag you're an idiot
papa pop all this stuff you said to your
own brother
to your own sister to your wife to your
mom to your dad to your
husband we've done this before if we
didn't have this
30 minutes later our emotions would have
been a little lower we would handle a
little bit different
what does that mean social media
gets our emotions here then it says
guess what you have a weapon
react right now so we're going oh my
gosh
what are you kidding me give me the
phone boom
do you understand what i'm saying to you
right so social media i don't know about
the whole social dilemma stuff the angle
they took which is fine
i'm more talking about emotions emotions
i cannot believe it
let me call my wife right now
[Music]
and the speed of emotional reaction
right now is very dangerous
the speed of emotional reaction right
now is very dangerous because
maybe 30 minutes more of time you had
maybe you wouldn't react it that way
maybe you want to react to that what if
you didn't say those choice words to the
person you did
what if you didn't well today you have a
tool to do that and i think
we're starting to realize one video that
was shot about george floyd which i'm
not telling it's a bad thing i'm telling
some form of accountability
for cops and all the people out there
that are thinking about doing any kind
of crime activity or anything they
shouldn't be doing illegal
it's a good tool but at the same time
like this
hundreds of thousands of people's
emotions go right here and what happens
you officially inject that emotion into
180 150
200 000 people to do something stupid
who pays a price for it
innocent people number 13 not all
conspiracy theories
are conspiracies we learn a lot of
different things so that's a conspiracy
theory oh that's a conspiracy theory
many conspiracy theories are conspiracy
theories but not all conspiracy theories
are conspiracies some of them actually
have some weight behind them
there were a lot of conspiracy theories
that went viral during the pandemic
5g is the cause of coronavirus 5g is
this and 5g is the
and this virus is really came from
africa no really came from iran
really made by us military know it
really so many don't look
which one do you believe in but some of
them are right some of them are right
what's the solution do your own
research goes back to the same thing do
your own research
every time i do a video i don't tell you
to believe the video go to your research
whatever video we did go do your own
research whatever interview we did
go do your own research don't sit there
just because you watch one video it's
100 accurate
go do your own research and find out for
yourself on what really is going on
number 14 is life
is fickle one minute we're celebrating
kobe getting an oscar next minute we're
celebrating his life
because he died of a helicopter accident
with his daughter gigi
and the world stopped everybody stopped
i have his jersey right there with his
picture and i
and i have a hard time watching his
interview i every once in a while i
watch it sometimes i don't want to watch
it oh did you watch the interview ever i
go oh it's a great interview with kobe
yeah of course it's a great interview
kobe i mean we really enjoyed the time
we spent together
like this poof gone
no kobe just so you know there is no
kobe bryant right
enjoy life man whoever you're with right
now even things are not going right man
one day you're gonna say i miss those
memories with whoever you are right now
think about some of the people that were
in your life ten years ago used to have
fun with
so what there was a falling out there's
not a following out right now make the
best of it
have a good time with it whatever you're
doing try to enjoy life
whether it's good bad or ugly figure out
a way to enjoy it because like this it
can be taken away from us
and i think that's a reminder that
sometimes even the most busy people like
myself
we all need that vermont i'm not telling
you believe me i'm telling this to
myself
just as much as i'm telling to everybody
else this year really made me enjoy my
time with my kids more
i so enjoy my time with my kids oh i
love
my time with these kids took my daughter
to we went out to our typical greek
restaurant we go to and she's sitting
right in front of me with her eyes like
this
and i said what's your name baby what's
your name and my son
dylan's like senna her name is sana why
do you keep asking and then she says
senna oh my you know i'm like i'm in
heaven cloud nine
life is like this enjoy every single
moment you got man 2020 taught us about
that
so fickle and last but not least not not
least
don't wait for another crisis to happen
for you to map out your next 5 10 15
moves don't wait for it
don't wait for the next crisis because
it's around the corner pretty much brace
yourself for impact could be happening
next five to ten years
we are going to have another massive one
happen 10 years from now
but be prepared what are you gonna do
next with everything
what are you going to do next if biden's
president what are you going to next if
trump doesn't lose what are you going to
do next if
you know war breaks out what are you
going to do next
if we get into trouble with china now
after what are you going to do next if
what are you going to do next what are
your next
don't rely on everything here you know
you got to constantly be thinking about
your next 5 10 15 moves constantly
too many people wait for life to happen
to think about their next 5 10 15 moves
always be in the mindset of 5 10 15
moves matter of fact if you
yourself every single time you were to
create a traditional
culture in your family and your company
every time something happened
if this became in the language of your
office you ready
okay guys um this is not good
what's our next five moves start saying
write it down
i think here's what we should do next
what do you think no i think we need to
do that third what do you think we need
to do that no here's what we need to do
first
here's our next five moves whatever
that's going on today the lessons we all
learn
about the pandemic in 2020
always have your next 5 10
15 moves prepared don't wait for a
crisis to happen
for you to have your next 5 10 15 moves
prepared so again like i said
stranger and i can probably give you 200
other lessons that you're probably going
to add
and i'd love to hear from you if you
want to comment below and say pat you
forgot this lesson you forgot that
lessons i really want to know comment
below
but if you watch this video and you
enjoyed it i got another video i want
you to watch
is how to prepare for the next market
crash eight ways
to prepare for the next market crash
because don't think for a moment the
market has crashed yet
because powell from federal reserve said
he's not raising interest rates
to zero above zero until 2023 a market
crash is coming
you prepared for it are you prepared to
maximize because it's coming
well you that it is coming but you got
to be ready for it
if you've not watched that video click
over here to watch that video having
said that
have a great day everybody take care bye
bye bye bye
[Music]